I recently discovered something
disturbing while reviewing my favorite
men's right subreddit there's a
witch-hunt against men in Silicon Valley
some men are even saying that the
feminists have formed a cabal whose goal
was to subjugate men it's the men who
are being fired for their so-called
sexist behavior Silicon Valley has been
battling allegations of mistreatment and
sexual harassment of women in the
workplace the memo which was published
in a few different publications has
sparked outrage here in Silicon Valley
that the lack of women working in tech
is attributable to biological
differences within days d'amour was
fired some people are asking if men are
the real victims in the tech industry
and I say yes I decided to make it my
mission to give the oppressed men of
Silicon Valley a voice so I reached out
to a ton of men but they all said no
probably because they were too scared to
come forward with their stories that's
when I finally found someone brave
enough Keith Keith had created a
successful e-commerce site called
whichcee so I went to go meet him in his
home office in Los Angeles to hear the
full story hi nice to meet you nice to
meet you too I'm here to see your boss
Keith man he's not real
[Laughter]
Keith these jokesters who are pretending
keith isn't real are penelope Gazin and
Kate Dwyer the founders of which see an
e-commerce site that specializes in
weird art that I don't get and frankly
find pretty disgusting so explain to me
how you think Keith man saved your
business well we created him yeah he's
not real
I pretended to be Keith on emails I made
the email Keith man which see at Gmail
because he was too busy to create the
email himself again he's not a real
person so you gotta be freaking me
ladies why would anybody make up a fake
man we fabricated him because we needed
a buffer when emailing with coders and
developers every time we would
communicate or email with a specific
developer he would never address us by
name but Kate noticed that whenever she
would use Keith's email to contact him
he would always start every email with
Keith
they were just quicker responses more
yeses less excuses every time that we
use a Keith email we developed the
character of Keith like he you know has
a wife created a Twitter yeah for him
jokes about Mondays oh my god he
actually was a tool for us we thought we
had to prove ourselves before we were
given respect words with Keith
he was just automatically given it is
this something that you would ever do
again yeah I would god now I was pissed
by giving a job to a fake man Penelope
and Kate were taking a job away from a
real man that was sexist a minutes the
most despicable after all executives in
Silicon Valley are only 89% men that's
not even in the 90s so it was time to
meet with some real men from tech and
have a professed to get to the bottom of
this but once again no
with me so I had to meet with a bunch of
women instead
yikes these man haters are all Silicon
Valley pros who work for companies like
GoPro Apple and reddit I just feel like
right now there is a witch hunt out
there for men led by feminist bullies
and it's super uncomfortable it's not a
witch hunt so we conducted a study with
over 200 women learning more about their
experience this was sexual harassment
they were saying that I don't want to
pursue a legal route
I don't want settlements I don't need
money all I want is for my company to
resolve this issue and for it to not
happen again we need a culture where we
respect everyone please stop ganging up
on me they were trying to tell you how
we feel and how things can improve well
it's not comfortable for me about men's
feelings these women were too focused on
their own problems like the fact that
only 5% of startups are run by women but
what about men what about men do men
have a safe space to network without
women I mean this seems like a huge
issue now and you wearing everywhere you
go the safe space for you I don't feel
safe right now
ooh that actually gives me a really
great idea I wanted to pitch my great
idea directly to a man but surprise
surprise the men were too afraid to meet
with me so I found Ari Horry she's the
CEO and founder of women's startup lab
as featured in Forbes and I'm a
confident man who has a great feeling
about this
[Music]
but I'm going to change the game weights
men men do not have a safe space in tech
linked men aims to make tech a safe
space for men once again wait man wait
man it's a stupid idea this is not a
charitable organization we believe in
invest in a company that has a viable
idea unbelievable I guess it was time to
go to one of the few places left that
are still safer men the sports bar or a
strip club or Congress or the White
House anymore over the world of online
video game or Hollywood that sports the
haircutting place I've been dying to try
out a South in general north also the
Midwest airplane Orleans biscuit
concert that the world is closing in on
us fellas take refuge where you can